[Musique]
et on commence ces informations Gabriel
par le conflit entre le Hamas et Israël
ce dernier a des conséquences en France
le ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald
dararmanin a dénoncé une recrudesence
d'acte antisémite oui et parmi les
personnes visées Gael Bron pivé la
députée des ivelines et présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale a reçu des menaces
de mort à son domicile elle a d'ailleurs
été placée sous protection Judici hier à
la suite d'un incident qui s'est déroulé
il y a 3 jours à l'Assemblée nationale
la parlementaire avait interdit l'accès
à l'hémicycle à une militante
palestinienne membre d'une association
classée terroriste par l'Union
européenne toujours sur le conflit entre
le Hamas et Israël un rassemblement a
été organisé hier à Versailles environ
200 personnes se sont mobilisées devant
l'Hôtel de Ville de Versailles
principalement issu de la communauté
juive un rassemblement qui avait pour
but de rendre hommage aux victimes de
l'attaque du Hamas en Israël on écoute
la réaction d'arier Tolédano leurabinde
de versaill on voyait des personnes
s'approcher vers pr de la communauté
vers les fidèles vers moi-même me dire
combien ils étaient sensibles à ce que
nous ressentons vraiment ça fait mon
chaud cœur ça vraiment des B m cœur
parce que cette fois-ci cétait
totalement unanime et on poursuit ces
informations Gabriel avec le verdict du
procès de l'attentat à maganville qui
est tombé il est tombé hier en fin
d'après-midi la Cour d'Assise spéciale
de Paris a condamné Mohamed Lamin
aberous à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité a sorti d'une peine de sûreté
de 22 ans il est reconnu coupable de
complicité pour le double assassinat de
Jessica schneeder et Jean-Baptiste
Salvin un couple de policiers tués à
leur domicile de magianville le 13 juin
2016 Mohamed Lamine aberou était le seul
accusé dans ce procès le terroriste
ayant été abattu par le Raid le jour de
l'attentat les avocats de la défense
font vont faire appel de cette
condamnation et on termine avec un mot
de rugby qui concerne le prochain
adversaire adversaire de l'équipe de
France à la Coupe du Monde oui l'Afrique
du Sud s'est entraînée aujourd'hui
devant la presse au centre
d'entraînement de croissie sur scène la
viille yvelinoise et le camp de base des
champions du monde en titre jusqu'à leur
quart de finale les springbx
affronteront les Bleus ce dimanche à 21h
au Stade de France bien merci beaucoup
Gabriel Gontier pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une image ou une
information près de chez vous n'hésitez
pas à nous la partager sur les réseaux
sociaux en utilisant le hashtag setet
news